The school's 10 best daiju lovers
[music]
One of the best resistances in Noir,
Koushin
[music] According to
Lazer-senpai's information, he's the most troublesome guy in Noir
.  Preliminary Battle 1
Hey, the opponent is a girl, so I'm going to push it with
my rawness.  I'll have it completed at
our school, Kazoin.
I'll send you the strongest plate by mail.
How far can the taste be enhanced in 15 minutes?
Thanks to the times, the assassination techniques used by the industry's single pillars and other influential ingredients continued to change the course of history.
It's an example of the successor to the soymilk moon Koshu style.
There's no way a little girl like you can compete with this country's ace, which has made the world
roar with its popularity
.
I don't do anything other than Usa [music]